hello everybody my name is sergeant
brian zink b-r-y-a-n-z-i-n-k
i'm the public information officer for
the clark county school district police
department
all right so we'll give you a quick
briefing we'll answer some questions and
then we'll provide phone numbers at the
end of the interview
for tip lines and things of that nature
okay
all right so today at approximately 8 52
a ccsd pd traffic officer initiated a
traffic stop
on a car at the 5600 block of cherokee
avenue
which is adjacent to harris elementary
school
the citizen in the car requested to
speak to a supervisor
the supervisor was uh with his traffic
detail while they were out doing traffic
approached the vehicle and interacted
with the driver the driver at that time
decided to roll up his window and drive
away
at that time the vehicle made contact
with the sergeant knocking him to the
ground
and unfortunately the officer's service
weapon was discharged
we do not believe at this time that
there were any injuries sustained by the
driver of the vehicle
the supervisor was uh was attended to by
medical and released on the scene
and has no major injuries this is an
ongoing investigation
ccsdpd is investigating we're being
assisted by the metropolitan police
department as you can see
we're doing this together it's annie
we're encouraging any citizens in the
area that may have any information that
please come forward you can call our
dispatch at 799.54
you can also call lvmpd dispatch and
give them information
and we're also encouraging the driver to
please come forward to give his side of
the story
so that we can we can figure out this if
we can do this investigation and get the
information
it gets taken care of have you been able
to locate the car yet
uh at this time the car has not been
located so it was an accidental
discharge of the firearm
but would he be still be facing some
charges he did knock your officer down
right there would be that that is part
of the investigation to see what exactly
happened if the car made contact with
the sergeant or if he fell down while he
was trying to
retreat from the vehicle as it was
driving away
he was knocked to the ground preliminary
it appears that he was knocked to the
ground as
the car drove off what kind of injuries
minor yeah
just uh so it was typical injuries it
was the same thing knocked to the ground
at a low impact was there an altercation
at any point between the sergeant and
the driver which then led the driver to
at this time we don't know again that
would all be on the body worn camera
which is under being reviewed right now
can you tell us what the initial car
stuff was uh i imagine it was just
traffic
this was an active school zone at that
time and so i believe they were just out
here conducting traffic
were out here doing their typical
traffic stops yes
yes this is our motors team how long
were they out here before
that i don't know i believe the school
started probably around 7 30
so probably right around they probably
got here right around that time
so do you have a description of the car
you want out there uh at this time it's
a black nissan
is the only information i've been
provided and the driver
any kind of description no he did not
identify himself
okay so it's a man do we have an age
range approximately
no was are there kids at the school
right now was the school put on lockdown
yeah the school was put on a soft
lockdown which is standard for
uh police activity in the area it's
still in a soft lockdown and it'll
remain that way until we leave
it has absolutely had no impact on
education because we've been inside the
school several times
kids have been going to and from class i
don't think most of the staffing side
don't even know what's going on out here
the fact that there is that to your
investigation
it's always very important you know it's
always our policy that whenever officers
have interaction with citizens that they
activate their cameras and so
uh we had probably three or four
different body cameras that were
on at the time and they're all under
review right now do you know when the
last time a ccsd
police officer's gun was fired at any
point
it's probably about five years ago we
had an officer involved shooting uh in a
park in henderson
this one was an accidental discharge
supervisor yes we're also assisted by
the ccsd police department k9 team also
came out and
did an area sweep of the area as well um
metro's crime
uh crime scene techs are out here doing
their job everybody's working like
this is another great example of how we
all work together in the community to um
you know keep everyone safe so and i'd
have to imagine because there is body
cam video
you're gonna be able to find this person
if they don't turn themselves in
you know what he looks like and what the
fun looks like hopefully yeah hopefully
that that will be the outcome
yeah hopefully there's a couple of
peaceful results so we're gonna go ahead
and end this i think the school's
getting ready to get out and traffic's
getting pretty you know so keep
everybody safe so
we'll be putting a statement out pretty
much the statement we just put out now
will be put out later on today as well
thank you very much all right thank you
everybody